this morning on the dish chef known for
blending food traditions of the American
north and south
Andy little grew up in Pennsylvania
Dutch country savoring the produce of
local farms after first aiming for a
career in classical music he started
supporting himself with restaurant work
and grew inspired to become a chef so he
headed off to the prestigious Culinary
Institute of America and started his
career five years ago
he became executive chef and partner at
joséphine in Nashville where
Pennsylvania Dutch and southern
hospitality meld together for a unique
and much honored cuisine chef Andy
little good morning welcome to the day
good morning thanks for having me tell
us about this Nashville table so let's
start with the cocktail so this is a
Manhattan made with red-eye rye and
actually a spirit that our original bar
manager has started so he's since moved
on to that I mean it's a beautiful
bottle just that I love my daughter's
cocktail yeah right I mean it's got a
little bit of a little bit of coffee in
it so I'm moving moving toward me
there's a little bit of Nashville hot
scrapple scrapple again from where I
came from in central Pennsylvania we
take it and coat it with Nashville hot
chicken spices so we have that direct
line between Pennsylvania and and
Nashville and then these beautiful whole
chicken with some kale and a little bit
of crispy potato and dandelion was was a
big thing growing up so we take the
dandelion and toss it with a little bit
of warm bacon vinaigrette a mushroom
potpie which is just amazing totally
vegetarian I'm working smoked the
mushrooms a little bit so a lot of times
people think they you snuck bacon in
there a little bit which we would like
to do but entirely vegetarian I'm happy
to hear that and then finishing with a
little strawberry and rhubarb crisp
crossing our fingers and hoping spring
comes a little sooner we heard some of
your story obviously in getting to you
you say you went from tuba to tender
laughter yeah really had this idea you
were going to have music as a career why
did that not happen for you I think I
just got to a point where I really
enjoyed the work of it I really enjoyed
going in and achieving something you
know but I'm not sure that I really
enjoyed the music part of it
yeah and there were people who just
loved going in sitting in the music
library and listening to classical music
and that wasn't me I would rather you
almost got a job in a company but you
said you then you kind of changing gears
you kind of faced your first real adult
decision yeah
yeah first real adult decision for sure
I just knew that I didn't love it and I
knew that I had to do something else and
being in my 20s something else was I'm
not sure what that's have to be
terrifying yeah you know well both of my
team and my parents are teachers and so
I went back to school one thought was
gonna be a teacher too and do the family
business syndrome in order to pay for
that I started to work in restaurants
Wow and you know there's this great
sense of community and teamwork
in restaurants and being a musician I
was already working nights I was already
working weekends and holidays and so the
pace and and timing of it all worked out
welfare and that led you to the CIA it
did and that's where I knew that it was
something that not only to enjoy the
work but I had a passion for because in
music school when people were listening
to all the classical music yeah I was
watching videos of the chefs that would
come to CIA to the point of I even took
some of those videos and put on my
backpack and thought I really want to
take these to my place what took you to
Nashville the job I was looking around
Nashville was certainly you know
Nashville's hot these days food scene
yeah yeah so you know I love music all
kinds of music so the rock and roll and
country and everything and just a
creative energy the Nashville has and
also the you know the growing economy
and business was just there's something
special about Nashville we get to eat
this right now what do you want diners
to experience from sort of this coming
together of foods that you have you know
so we're actually you know we've got all
of this food here the one thing that is
really important to me though is that
the entire dining situation makes sense
so you go in and you have this great
food but you also have a wonderful
service experience and you just you
leave the restaurant feeling better than
you did when you came in we will have
you sign our dish if you could have this
meal with anyone past or present who
would it be so I'm a lucky guy my
parents just moved to Nashville oh yeah
I get to work with my wife every day and
every day 3:30 I sit down with the best
restaurant team and have a meal so be a
little self-indulgent I say I'd like to
do this with Bruce Springsteen that's
good Bruce thank you thank you thank you
and for more on chef little and the dish
you can head to our website at CBS this
morning dot-com